alors c'est quoi alors c'est un mélange
d'eau et de mileena baïse et là on va
rappeler ce que c'est c'était pas de
farine dont je viens c'est de l'amidon
de maïs alive voilà donc la schl à ces
jeux là là ces flux et de voiliers en
revanche si je suis en mouvement ses
impressions que c'est une cata ces
tissus en mourir et la cdu auriez là
c'est dur si j'arrête up est alors
grandeur nature imaginées
j'ai rempli se bat là ouais l'appareil
c'est fluide oui
ah oui c'est comme de l'eau près ces
jours ci je mettais dans my
prochainement fonds spa ah ouais mais
bon vous avez pas vous enfoncez beaucoup
de regarder oui oui
ah oui c'est vrai ou faux pas est en
fait le nom du tonnerre hélas oui il ya
des faits ni arrêt à essayer voulait pas
lancer ou vous pas voilà au puissant
pour pas j'ai tapé une expérience de
merde mais ça me alors moi je vous
fabriquer du gaz carbonique et je vais
parler sous le contrôle du professeur
castaldi k1 connais très bien cette
expérience il n'a pas arrêté de m'en
parler
il n'a même pas nous auriez pas pu
ouvrir le trucage non il valait je loue
va mal on m'a dit mouvement au dernier
moment alors excusez moi je vois là je
fais ce que je peux
alors ça c'est de la glace la brasse
carbonique alors il faut pas la
manipuler clairmarais surtout pas je
vais la mettre là dedans
ouais mais là il faut de l'eau en
revanche il a le talent est là
merci merci et attention regardez bien
ce qui va se passer dans les criées ce
qui va se passer et que ça va créer du
gaz carbonique qui sera plus léger que
l'air c'est bien ça un plus lourd plus
lourd pardon travers bright and aliens
qu'est ce qui va se passer là ya de la
fumée lourdes normalement normalement
qui tout va bien écrit pas tu devrais
avoir de la fumée voilà tu vois c'est
pour ça qu'il nous fait chier depuis
tout à l'heure
attendez votre caca qui fume on va
rendre l'âme
c'est très impressionnant c'est vous
regardez voilà c répond non c'est
vachement bien on avait déjà la mer
concert bah oui c'est vraiment de la
merde moi je vais vous montrer que quand
on remplit un sac de congélation en
plastique et qu on le remplit d'eau on
peut transpercer avec des crayons sans
que l'eau s'échappe du web un bayou à à
merde ça alors mais d'affirmer le machin
tu as vite le faire voilà oui mais
d'affirmer cher aussi
oui je serai pas toujours là au bac tu
seras toute seule ma peine a combattu
sera tout seul tu seras dans la merde
dans une merde noire mais parce que si
vous pourriez me lui tenir après ces
livres qui paie tout va mal finir
vasily félin truc là voilà voyez si je
fais ça et ça va alors une balle de ping
pong
ouais c'est très inflammables t'attend
garde quand même pas du tout fait pour
c'est vous parce que lui faisant perdre
au jeu l'enveloppent légèrement après la
grille ouvrez tous là je ne sens pas du
tout là c'est un peu dangereux mais
normal on se mettrait il va faire si tu
le laisses une cheminée ne le fait pas
chez vous non non pas du tout je laisse
une cheminée je laisse une cheminée pour
la balle de match va créer quoi je crée
le feu poussez-vous isabelle ça
s'appelle le fumigène maison avait fait
gaffe à ton s'est écartée je ne suis pas
le fumigène
normalement la salle à ça commence à
brûler bon moi je me barre il va tout
péter ce qu il d'ailleurs un problème
c'est que ça brûle pas c'est pour rire
et les deux là c'est un fiasco
j'ai une bouteille en verre j'ai de
l'eau à l'intérieur ceux de l'eau
normale
je prends une balle de ping pong heures
et doute vrai jeu rebouche la bouteille
oui ayalon elles sont pas bâlois elles
t'ont pas vrai et regardez
chez vous chez vous vous qui fait la
france a un incroyable talent
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est fort comment il a fait parce
que la balle est vraiment j'ai pas fais
vente élevé de l'air et l'oxygène comme
ça on l'a rendu prisonnier et ça fait à
créer un phénomène d'aspiration un appel
d'air du coup ça voilà avant tout il ya
le docteur à neuf qui lie alors j'ai un
magnifique cercle oui formé par des
bonbons à montrer les traits des
conneries montrer la caméra à l'épaule
et assiettes creuses away et je vais
verser à l'intérieur mais qu'est ce qui
va se passer expliqué nous qu'il va y
avoir une sorte de dessins de mosaïque
de couleurs multicolores sur cette
assiette et salah c'est ça l'expérience
est dévoilée police avait trouvé preneur
sur notre article je vais mettre de
l'eau un petit peu chaude c'est de la
vraie aux gens c'est de l'eau chaude
doit donc là on a besoin de quoi pour
les téléspectateurs une bouilloire et
l'eau est à 80 degrés elle est très très
chaud donc attention à chez vous et vous
mettez juste et quoi c'est les crs ddm
lm ce cd skittles épaules de ces décès
et ouvert cette fois c'est vous le dire
si on n'avait pas commencé de l'assiette
ans et le résultat est très jolie belge
était très jolie principe oui on se
régale à magnifique en fait ça font quoi
oui la merde en boite n'ont ils pas ces
jeunes et moi c'est une oeuvre en work
in progress leur secret ça c'est très
bon mais c'est quand même aller à fond à
temps les bonnes et huawei et pearl away
sa sénat cette fête des périodes là
c'est ça qu'il faut avoir un soda d'une
marque on citera pas plus d des mentos
voilà l'aimons tous prions à trévise en
fait il ya plein de petites aspérités
laxiste qu'on appelle des espaces son
physique des espaces de nucléation est
élu il explique bien que jamais en
plongeant les manteaux dans l'eau
gazeuse 5 croquer une réaction en chaîne
des bulles d'oxygène qui brassent
comptable remontés à la surface et
provoqué au passé qu'est ce qui est fort
j'espère que certains exposants voici le
doigt
rien a laissé le faire c'est un
professionnel ouais ça va péter n'est
pas c'est beau avec cette bouteille
d'eau et se poivre je vais vous montrer
l'attention des molécules à la surface
de l'eau vous sais même pas ce qu'elle
dira je vous dit à l'elfe au maroc est
alors à la surface de l'eau les
molécules d'eau formule membrane du tout
tendues l'antisèche sur la table j'avais
le choix des camps qui en suit donc je
mets un peu d'eau ici dans ce dans cette
assiette
je mets du coin le coup de poivre vous
allez voir que le poivre serait parti de
façon uniforme sur l'ensemble du truc
je vais mettre du liquide mais ce coton
tige au moyen orient mais quand ça vous
allez voir que le liquide vaisselle va
faire que le poivre se dispersent sur
les bords de l'assiette est assez génial
j'ai prévenu on va terminer on va
terminer sur cette expérience
bienvenue à voir bien voir deux
présidents de près ouais connais le
huawei franchement pas mal c'est bien
mais j'adore ce truc là je me fait mal
cet ennemi je mets cet ennemi l'honneur
alors ça c'est pas dangereux et les
enfants peuvent toujours faire voilà
vous pouvez faire les mots le manteau ça
attention ça sent peut le refaire les
bonbons c'est très sympa ça met tout de
suite l'ambiance en milieu campagnard en
milieu agricole urbain ça fait toujours
son succès ah ouais ça ça oui mais ça
c'est ripoux alors voilà ça ne le fait
pas voilà je vous le dis